[Music]
i'm chucky wanna play
it's october 31st
hackensack is a haven for the bizarre
the f'ed up and the straight-up
criminally insane
historically speaking the violence in
our fair city has always spiked on
halloween
where'd you get this
i have no idea 20 bucks not fair
this creepy doll just creeps me the hell
out me too
hi
i'm chucky
hello yeah i'm calling you about the
doll what
be very careful with that doll what are
you talking about
have you checked his batteries
[Music]
there's this urban legend about charles
lee redd
he was a serial killer who died in the
80s he terrorized chicago for years
prolific
before he died he transferred his soul
into a good guy doll
hi
i'm chuckie
wanna play
it was your standard voodoo soul
transfer chucky broke us all into pieces
the last piece didn't go into a doll
hello chucky
long time
no see
today is my lucky day
charles lee ray was born in hackensack
he's back in his hometown on a mission
we have big plans for this place
it's kill or be killed
no one knows what's going on
i'm too old for this [ __ ]
[Music]
you